517 ce sera le signe de clôture mais
avant ça y est à la cérémonie de clôture
avec l'annoncé fille est l'un des prix
les plus attendus c'est la caméra d'or
le p qui récompense le meilleur premier
film du festival toutes sélections
confondues
on a parlé juste il ya quelques instants
avec la présidente du jury de la caméra
d'or mélanie thierry et boutella mélanie
thierry
c'est la dernière fois que je peux vous
appeler madame la présidente c'est sa
banque n'aurait jamais tremblé menant la
présidente du jury de la caméra d'or
s'est fait acclamer comme fait sourire
tous à sa maman alors ça y est vous avez
pris de décision vous avez fait vos
choix comment se sont passées les
délibérations sous zones marines quand
on a passé 12 jours merveilleux
nabu découvrir trente et un films et
après ça c'est tour 10 ans a fool
vertige lorsqu'on voit des choses
magnifiques qui viennent de partout et à
un moment il faut
on désigne et quand il y en a qu'un seul
donc forcément c'est douloureux semanya
même quelque chose tout
qui nous dépasse parce que
est ce qu'on s'en rende compte de
l'enjeu parce qu'on se rend compte de ce
que ça représente et 2
mais c'était il y avait un cinéma où il
y avait tellement de souffler également
deux possibilités
et on nous a donné à voir tellement des
choses
payet magnifique où à la fois
on est ému à la fois on est admiratif et
impressionné mais voilà
et qu'on 106 me béguin
non je dirai pas qui allie la garonne
séjour à mai après forcément il ya des
moments doute ya des moments
d'incertitude
et puis quand on sent la pression
[Musique]
même peut-être perdre pied même si on
reste fidèle à à ce que
ressorti à nos émissions anna quelque
chose d'instinctif
après c'est très subjectif merci d'être
avec nous toujours en direct sur canal
plus on approche du coup d'envoi de
cette cérémonie